so should MPS actually be paid more to
stop them behaving in this grasping way
in the first place we're joining me now
is the podcast host and author of an
immigrants live ladder to the West
Constantine kissing constantly welcome
back to the program um great to do your
podcast by the way I've had a great
reaction to it good bad and ugly which
is the perfect reaction to anything
thanks for coming on um this when you
watched all this and it's in his full
gory details it was so gruesome to watch
and it was the usual suspect Hancock
quatting didn't surprise me at all the
quieting had very little grasp on
reality of money I love the way it said
yearly Railway he's not upselling you
already I did enjoy that what I mean
your takeaway from that was that you
have a belief that MP should be paid a
lot more money I'll just say I sort of
share that view I sort of think if you
paid peanuts you get monkeys right and
we're paying peanuts and getting people
who just seem to me to be extremely low
caliber
politicians and we need to somehow raise
that bar would money alone do that do
you think well the the headline to pay
them more is what people took away from
what I've been saying about this my view
is yes you pay them more but you then
also ban them from you say they're
allowed to have second jobs they're
allowed to have third jobs and fourth
jobs and fifth jobs so as long as the
incentive structure is there they're not
getting paid a huge amount for the job
that they're doing obviously compared to
the ordinary person they're they're
being paid for a chunk of money but
compared to other people operating at
the top of society I mean if you wanted
your favorite football club to be run by
someone who's very good you'd happily
pay them three four million a year right
in Singapore they pay apparently their
politicians a lot of money yeah millions
of dollars so they take your view that
you then attract the best talent your
country benefits it's actually a small
price to pay you get what you pay for
and I think with them you have to ban
the second third and fourth jobs and so
on and you have to make sure that they
put the uh stocks and shares in the
trust where they don't get uh benefits
from companies being trade in a certain
way and whatever but the bottom line is
pissed you get what you pay for and it's
interesting I mean you don't have to get
better people into Parliament right so
Singapore they get 672
000 pounds a year for an average Member
of Parliament Singapore Spain is only 49
000. Germany 108 000 United States
senators 142 000 pounds and France just
under 80 000 pounds so I guess by
comparison to most of Europe ours get
this you know in the kind of middle
range of that but Singapore dramatically
different and they believe over there
they really does attract a better
caliber and that makes perfect sense to
me I just I just think the pro one of
the biggest problems with our politics
is people think about tribe rather than
results and if you're tribal about this
you go well you know Hancock and
quieting of course but actually cast
your mind back to the black government
it's not like they were all squeaky
clean either we have a system in which
the incentive structure encourages
politicians not to take money from us
and to serve us we have a political
system where they take money from some
in this okay some pretend Korean company
and who are they then serving well
exactly I completely agree I want to
switch another story which I thought
would uh would probably get your
interest the Guardian newspaper owners a
guardian being the most woke newspaper
on planet Earth absolutely Beyond
reproach and they've LED Council culture
they've LED wokery they are purer than
pure whiter than white in all things
ethical and they've had an unfortunate
moment today because the Scott trust
that owns a guardian has had to issue a
public apology because it turns out the
origins of the wealth used to establish
the guardian Came From Slavery a review
found the papers founder John Edward
Taylor had links to slavery through
Partnerships in Cotton manufacturing
obviously the guardian reactions to fall
on its knees beg for mercy announce all
sorts of initiatives to prove they're
not a bunch of of racists and so on
you'd expect that from the guardian but
a comical irony that the paper that's
driven probably more than any
publication in the world this kind of
woke mentality and been picturing
everybody else about their own
shortcomings gets caught like this this
is a very good example of this whole
thing more generally where most of these
people who claim to be kind and
compassionate they behave in the most
awful ways towards the people that they
disagree with and I think this is where
you know I'm not I don't spend a lot of
time reading the guardian I'm not going
to cancel that it's actually bad for my
mental health so I don't but what I do
think is you know everyone lives in a
glass house to some extent and I think
what I take out of this is we should all
throw stop throwing rocks around because
I I genuinely think that if you dig down
long enough every one of us has some
ancestor who did something wrong and the
less we we focus on things that happen
300 years ago and the more we come
together and try to solve the problems
of today I think the better offers
self-flagellation over historical stuff
which current people had nothing to do
with what's the point you know it's like
this thing in San Francisco we're
looking to pay millions and millions of
dollars to every black person who lives
in San Francisco as some kind of
reparations for what previous
generations did hundreds of years ago I
don't understand how that helps anybody
no it doesn't and as you know I talk
about it in the book and the issue of
slavery more broadly I just think we've
got stuck in the past and the way that's
completely unhelpful many of the
conversations we have now in the west
are about looking Inward and going why
are we so bad why are we so wrong in the
case I'm making an immigrants love
letter to the West is we live in one of
the most open tolerant genuinely
Progressive Societies in the history of
humanity let's appreciate that let's at
least notice that for God's sake when do
we stop celebrating our country right I
feel the same way about America new poll
came out today saying the majority of
Americans the first time I can remember
now no longer think it's the best
country in the world Americans always
used to do that right now they don't
there's a kind of again
self-flagellation about the state of the
countries now whereas America and
Britain in many ways are two of the
great countries of the world today
unquestionably and uh to me it's
mind-boggling that we're in this
position but beyond being sort of
frustrated and got all these pink-haired
idiots are running around ruin whatever
to me this is a real threat peas because
if we in the west do not have the
strength of our convictions we do not
have the courage to stand up and say
you know our history is the same as the
history of every other Society we've
done good and bad but on balance we're
good we're good people we are people who
are doing good in the world
um then then other people will come and
take over you know the best works the
best people ever
in the history of this planet have all
been flawed Geniuses right I'm talking
to one and you're facing one
two prime examples constantly great to
see immigrants love that as the West
really excellent book making the points
you just make good to see you I
appreciate it thank you
[Music]